welcome back to las vegas now the pure
aloha spring festival returns to craig
ranch regional park and it's the perfect
way to escape to paradise joining us
today is shawn santana to tell us all
about the festivities sean how are you
doing great all right this is the 19th
year obviously you're doing something
right because you guys have been going
strong tell us about the festival what
can people expect when they come out
well what they're gonna expect is um a
unique unique experience um it's better
than going to hawaii because you
actually compile everything you go to
hawaii all in one place four days so we
have food i mean we have um cultural
performances entertainment we have
evening concerts with some
big name um concert people from hawaii
that's gonna be performing every evening
and we have these people here i mean
they performed in every event for 19
years as well they i've grown up with
them the event has grown with them also
oh wow well you guys have to play a
little something while we're talking we
got to start setting the mood because we
have a fun performance coming up here
soon and you can see some video on the
screen so much entertainment oh you're
getting in the mood here you got food a
little bit of everything where and when
can people come hang out just me what's
that again when can they come hang out
the event is in three days april 21st
the 24th craig ranch regional park in
north las vegas see i had us playing the
music and now it's too loud in here
we're getting ready for the party and we
have a special troupe coming in before
we bring them in tell us a little bit
about them and you know some of the
other talent that we can see out there
well tewakanui has actually grown with
the event i mean from
maybe the second event on until today so
they've grown as a group also and
they've been very supportive of me and
the festival and we've also been
supportive of them and we have groups
coming in from california and hawaii and
several different other states to
perform also oh well all we need right
now are some sunglasses and a cocktail
in hand and we're ready to go
we're going to put all the information
on your screen really quickly so you can
attend the pure aloha festival happening
april 21st and 24th and to close it out
we're going to bring in this incredible
dance triple let you ladies take it away
[Music]
[Music]
you